this morning michael saylor the founder
of microstrategy announced that the
company has bought another 301 bitcoin
for about six million dollars now before
you laugh at a measly six million dollar
purchase coming from a multi-billionaire
with a company with a multi-billion
dollar market cap understand this
microstrategy now holds about 130
000 bitcoin making that nice round
number possible for the technology
company on top of that this six million
dollar purchase is a big big statement
coming from michael saylor that he still
has deep conviction in bitcoin bitcoin
hit an all-time high price of 69 000
back in november of 2021 and it has
fallen about 70 or so since then but
michael saylor one of the biggest
bitcoin bulls he continues to accumulate
as much bitcoin as he possibly can the
price drop has scared away lots of
institutions and many retail investors
but to see the very first publicly
traded company to ever put bitcoin on
their balance sheet continuing to
accumulate whether it's six billion
dollars or simply six million dollars
it's a big big deal michael then went on
to state that microstrategy now has
spent about 3.98 billion dollars to
acquire their 130 000 bitcoin at an
average price of just over 30 000
this means that michael and
microstrategy are underwater on their
total bitcoin purchase but i don't think
that they're worried about the
day-to-day price fluctuation michael
saylor has talked over and over again
that bitcoin is a great store of value
and it's something with a backdrop of
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
that likely you'll want to hold for long
periods of time it is crazy to see
somebody who started buying bitcoin
around 10 000
and continued to buy all the way up to
that 69 000 all-time high price and now
is buying all the way down into the 20
000 range as you see the volatility of
bitcoin occur those that dollar cost
average tend to buy the tops the bottoms
and everywhere in between it'll be
fascinating to watch how this trade
works out for somebody like
microstrategy my guess is that this ends
one of two ways it's either the greatest
trade in all of wall street history or
it ends up in a big fiery crash with a
hole in the ground what do you think
will end up happening to microstrategy
and their billions of dollars of bitcoin
let me know in the comments and i'll
jump in there later today and let you
know whether i agree or not hey you did
you like this video great make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time